[Music]
when the kids who are obsessed with duke
snake eyes and scarlet watch gi joe as
adults
they probably noticed some things from
the stuff that's even better than you
remember to the episodes that are just
too weird here are the things only
adults notice in gi joe
the opening credits of every episode of
gi joe describe
cobra as a ruthless terrorist
organization determined to rule the
world
but when you go back to watch the show
as an adult it's easy to see them as a
little less terrorist and a little more
corporate america sure they occasionally
pull off schemes like building a machine
that will literally burn up all the
money in the world
or stashing nuclear missiles at fast
food restaurants
but structurally speaking they really
have a lot more in common with amazon
than isis
that mostly comes through in the comics
where we learn that cobra commander got
a start
basically running a pyramid scheme and
lured potential sleeper agents into
joining his cause
by offering competitive salaries and
even health insurance complete with a
dental plan
of course the dentistry had to be done
by dr meinbender
whose standard uniform of cape giant
metal cod piece
and zero shirts might make you
reconsider getting treatment for all but
the most painful toothaches
but benefits are benefits folks the
cartoon however
follows along and the glimpses that we
get of cobric corporate show that they
actually treat their employees way
better than the good guys do
take the viper is coming for instance an
episode based on the classic playground
joke of receiving an
ominous phone call informing you that
the viper is coming
the viper only for a friendly heavily
accented maintenance man to show up to
vipe the windows while the joe scramble
around
trying to locate the mysterious viper
they wind up uncovering a secret
cobra facility at the south pole devoted
entirely to recreation
cobra soldiers are allowed to swim and
play table tennis in the cobra commander
gymnasium
grab a meal at the destro dining room
and even catch a performance by a dance
company called the cobra cuties
it's so thoroughly pleasant that it's
kind of easy to see why so many people
could get past the whole
overthrow america thing referring to
cobra as in any way realistic is a
pretty huge stretch
but there's one aspect of the
organization that seems pretty authentic
they're always broke
it makes sense that they would be too
his tanks and weather dominators don't
come cheap
by the serpents
five billion dollars the thing is
you never really see mumrah or the
decepticons having to figure out their
budgets
with cobra it's what they're doing most
of the time sinister plots like the
attempted robbery of fort knox are all
about securing funding
for other even more improbable plots by
the time the show gets to the latter
half of its second season
things are getting so dire for cobra
that they're forced to have a straight
up telethon
where they beg for donations from the
rest of the international terrorist
community
when you're watching destro having to
put on a cheap tuxedo and awkwardly beg
vaguely offensive stereotypes for
charity you know things have gotten
pretty rough
speaking of cobra's increasingly
improbable fundraising tactics
one of their more audacious schemes came
when they attempted to steal the entire
state of alaska
it happens in the appropriately titled
episode the great alaskan land rush
which revolves around cobra discovering
an obscure provision in william seward's
purchase of alaska from russia
in 1867. the big idea is that whoever
has the state
seal of alaska is the state's true owner
so cobra gets their hands on a passable
fake and then declares
ownership of the state as a kid when
your entire life is governed by
seemingly arbitrary rules about nap time
and chores
this makes perfect sense who the sam
hill are you
the new owner of alaska hockey puck get
away from my desk
as an adult however this doesn't seem
like a well-considered plan
you may already know this from the
entirety of history but claiming
ownership of a massive chunk of land
that has been considered to be part of
another country for 120 years
is slightly more difficult than just
showing up with a fancy teacup
no matter how nice your accessories are
that tends to prompt things like
massive direct military action that goes
a lot further than just
sending four dudes with laser guns to
chase you around the tundra for 20
minutes
believe it or not the attempt to ocean's
11 alaska
is not cobra's most ridiculous plot that
dubious honor would likely go to cold
slither
the episode about a band named cold
slither and their hit song
cold slither for the kids in the
audience this might seem like one of
cobra's more deviously subtle plans for
world domination
the bad guys disguise the dread knocks
as a hair metal band and use an evil
super computer to lace their music with
mind controlling subliminal messages
that hypnotize their listeners into
absolute obedience to cobra on paper
this is a pretty good plan
and it even works on a couple of the
ridiculously loyal eternally patriotic
joes
who become mindless zombies after about
four seconds of listening to it
leaving the rest of the team to puzzle
through the mystery of why they've
suddenly got a handful of traitors on
their hands
and they just kept saying cold slither
cold slither cold slither
sounds like cobra stuff to me once you
grow up and revisit the episode however
the plot isn't quite as covert as it
seemed the first time around
for one thing the dreadnocks already
kind of look like a hair metal band
so dressing them up as a slightly
different hair metal band
is not the best disguise second and
probably more importantly
cult slither is about as subliminal as a
brick to the head
the actual explicit lyrics of the song
includes
freedom of expression is obviously very
important but if taylor swift dropped a
hot new track about how listeners should
swear loyalty to a terrorist
organization
it probably wouldn't get a whole lot of
radio play
at heart gi joe is a franchise based
around the sort of sci-fi
military aesthetic for the most part all
of the joe's playset-ready equipment are
all based
on real world counterparts cobra on the
other hand gets a little weirder with it
but at the end of the day
everything tends to line up with the
real world well until they start
fighting ghosts and monsters that is
yeah it turns out that in the world of
gi joe the supernatural is a 100
real problem that the united states
military has to address
it's not even in some secret area 51
sort of way either
it happens all the time cobra summons
ghosts to fight their battles for them
the joes straight up have to fight set
the falcon-headed egyptian god of fire
and destro literally has gigantic
shambling lovecraftian horror in the
basement of his ancestral home that his
family has been worshiping through human
sacrifice for centuries
and that's before you get to the movie
and the twist that cobra commander was a
snake man from a hidden society of
actual monsters
if you go back and watch an episode of a
show like he-man and the masters of the
universe
you probably wouldn't be surprised to
find that it's almost unbearably simple
and padded out with recycled shots of
characters just running around for no
reason
after all it's another one of those toy
commercial cartoons and since those
things only had to be good enough to get
kids interested in action figures
they were all kind of simplistic and bad
right
wrong well not about masters of the
universe that thing is pretty atrocious
ready boys ready
g.i joe on the other hand could be
shockingly smart and well crafted
especially for a show that was mostly
built around the simplistic premise of
good guys
fighting bad guys never tell anyone your
home alone
and never give anyone your address i'll
say mom can't come the phone
smart thinking now i know just look at
cobra's candidate
an episode where introducing a new
action figure is secondary to teaching
children that politicians are lying to
you
the premise seems simple enough thanks
to his hawkish
law and order platform mayoral candidate
robert harper has become a target for
cobra
with the commander's minions
intimidating voters and demanding that
they support his bleeding heart
soft on crime opponents gi joe has been
tasked with protecting him
which seems like a pretty standard setup
except that it actually turns out that
it's harper himself who's in bed with
cobra
and the attacks are just a tactic to get
sympathy from voters and make him seem
like he's capable of dealing with a
crisis that doesn't exist
all while profiting from fear sure it's
a fantastical story
but as adults we're pretty impressed by
the show illustrating how democracy can
be twisted by the ruthless and power
hungry
welcome aboard mr harper i'm not sure
you can vote for yourself in jail
we'll have to ask a judge
not all of gi joe's adult-oriented
details have to do with goofy quirks
some of them are downright horrifying
like a two-part saga of
there's no place like springfield which
contains some pure
unadulterated nightmare fuel the episode
was heavily inspired by the surreal 1966
british series the prisoner
in which a former spy is confined to a
mysterious island called the village
where he psychologically tortured in
elaborate occasionally dreamlike
scenarios in an effort to break him
and discover his secrets you know
exactly the sort of thing you'd want to
adapt into a 22-minute toy commercial
in gi joe's version scripted by the
famously offbeat comic book writer steve
gerber
shipwreck wakes up after a mission to
find himself as an older man who's been
retired from the joes for years but has
no memory of the intervening time
he's confronted with both a family he
doesn't remember having
and other retired joes some of whom
blame him for lady jay's death
while he suspects something is wrong
with the whole scenario
it isn't until he watches people melt
into puddles of goo
in front of him that viewers learn the
whole thing is a plot by cobra
to make him give up classified
information by putting him in a village
full of synthoids
eventually he makes it through okay but
the episode left plenty of viewers
thinking about it and discovering new
layers to the psychodrama as they grew
into adulthood
the extensive cast of gi joe is
explicitly designed to be large and
inclusive enough so that every kid can
have their favorite character
the big reason for this is of course to
sell more action figures
but it has the pleasant side effect of
giving the show a level of diversity
that's still pretty impressive over 30
years later
even though everybody's favorite is
snake eyes with all these characters
almost every joe gets some kind of
spotlight over the course of the series
from lady jay being swept up in the
gothic horror of destro's basement
to the genuinely disturbing implications
of lowlight's abuse of childhood
however a few characters don't come off
that great for proof
check out the most dangerous thing in
the world where the producers clearly
decided that dial tone and lifeline
were not and would never be anyone's
favorite characters
and that they could go ahead and do an
entire episode about how much they
sucked at their jobs
as part of an attempt to destroy the
joe's morale cobra hacks into their
personnel system
picks the three worst candidates for
leadership and promotes them all to the
rank of colonel
lifeline a pacifist who comes off like a
whiny parody written by someone who
truly hates non-violence
doesn't want the job oh no
this is terrible what's wrong been
transferred
no worse i've been promoted
and dial tone who's basically a human
radio wants the job but is terrible at
it
so the entire episode is about them
screwing up so disastrously that
everyone almost
dies multiple times weirdly enough while
he seems like he got the worst of it
when we watched while we were kids
shipwreck who had neither the ability
nor the desire
and is therefore the perfect millennial
hero comes off in retrospect as the
coolest person on the entire team
with the success of the marvel cinematic
universe it seems like everyone's trying
to build a sprawling
interconnected franchise that spans
multiple genres as a unified whole
the dc characters have had mixed results
with a film franchise and a weirdly
complicated tv universe
and while they started with the premise
as simple as frankenstein and dracula
know each other
universal has failed to launch their
monstrous version twice
the thing is gi joe was knocking that
stuff out back in 85.
see there's this character named hector
ramirez a tv journalist who once
interviewed cobra commander and popped
up in a few episodes
usually for the sake of exposition good
evening tonight's big story is one of
america's elite gi joe team
a traitor the thing is ramirez also
showed up in the transformers and on gem
and the holograms
meaning that those shows all take place
in the same hasbro universe
but wait it gets weirder in humanoids a
show about
giant subterranean monsters who rise up
from an underground kingdom to destroy
the world
also features ramirez and one of the
characters on the show is implied to be
a joe named brad
armbruster who changed his code name
from ace to saber jet when he got into
the monster fighting business
it doesn't stop there cops a show about
super police dealing with the scourge of
cyborg gangsters and fighting crime in a
future time
is set in the same universe too dig deep
enough and there's probably a connection
with the cast of my little pony
somewhere in there also
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite classic tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one